allez parlons de notre gros bébé du jour
l'airbus a380 qui a été donc sorti de
son hangar tout à l'heure à toulouse
blagnac sur lui on vous a déjà tout dit
qu'il était le plus beau le plus gros le
plus large qu'il pourra transporter
jusqu'à 800 passagers qu'il pourra aller
jusqu en australie sans escale qu'il va
damer le pion à boeing mais ces sauces
et son la halle avalanche de superlatifs
voici l'animal en piste à toulouse arno
boutet lécher la première image forte et
unie côte à côte le français jacques
chirac l'allemand gerhard schröder
l'espagnol josé luis zapatero et le
britannique tony blair
les quatre pays fondateurs d'airbus
industrie envahi ce hall d'assemblage
transformée en salle de ce cheval et qui
enivre qui indique le chemin la marche
tout commence par un conte imaginaire
exister airbus ouvre son grand livre de
l'innovation la 3 xx devient
officiellement l'a380 pied-de-nez au
concurrent boeing
plusieurs acheteurs du gros porteur dont
quelques américains viennent vente et
les prouesses de l'appareil à midi le
rideau tombe dans la pénombre l'avion
dévoile ses cours
à la tribune les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement rivalisent de superlatifs
dans toutes les langues
ce véritable paquebot du ciel fera date
dans l'histoire de l'aviation comme les
hold clément ader comme la caravelle
comme le concorde b6 comme cet avion ça
est le plus impressionnant au monde et
noir et sm c'est le symbole de la
puissance économique et de l'innovation
technologique et servions cet avion
commentant dans la soute chose que
l'homme a réalisé dans l'histoire c'est
la réalisation d'un rêve
la réalisation d un choix niant jamais
airbus n'avait organisé une telle fête
réuni autant de monde pour la sortie
d'un appareil ce spectacle se veut à la
hauteur du nouveau défi d'airbus le
défit commercial